i want to start with how much i loved
the first four episodes of andor uh
they're so effing good um i i just want
to throw that out there so everyone
knows um i think my favorite part is
that there is no jedi lightsabers desert
planets called tatooine um it's just all
new it's just an all-new section of star
wars uh can you talk about that aspect
of the show yeah um it really is the the
true origin story of such a great
character that we already know and love
um i see the cat hi cat great exactly um
and and and i think tony did such a
great job of
creating these new worlds that are so
intricate and so
so smart and interesting um
ferrix for example is is is
a
place where sort of everyone is is
everyone is sort of the same there's you
don't see like hierarchies and and
economical disbalances everyone's sort
of a worker and they all sort of share
things and trade it's very much like a
trading system
um
and there's a community there then you
feel it and and there are
um
rituals and traditions that are very
much from pharynx and what happens to to
a place like this when they're at a cusp
of a revolution like
what do you what do you think that
ignites and that's pretty epic and and
realizing where
cassian is truly from and and then
getting to go to ferrix and
understanding where
you know he lived most of his life um
it's kind of epic to to see it and and
and to understand it it's
so real and and that's the one thing
that really i just keep saying that word
over and over because it truly is so
real it's it's about people it's
ordinary people that have very little in
common
um
but they sort of are bound
together and it's sort of an imagery of
of who we are as as a society and it's
it's pretty it's pretty remarkable what
tony has created i i never asked the
generic question but because i'm gonna
air this
way before the series is out um like how
would you describe your character and
the relationship to cassian i bix is is
someone that isn't afraid of getting her
hands dirty she's a risk taker um
she is bold and fearless and she is a
manager at a sal yard so has a you know
pretty steady life and pretty um
you know she she kind of has everything
under control and then here comes
cassian and then it sort of always
happens and their dynamic is one that i
love
deeply and was so it was so fun to sort
of dig in and and
and play around with it you know their
childhood friends and you can sense that
they have a history and and
their dynamic is complicated
and it's you can almost tell that their
trust has been built and broken and
built and broken over the course of of
many many years yet she's incredibly
caring and incredibly protective over
him sometimes even at her own detriment
for star wars fans what do you think
they would be surprised to learn about
the making of andor they built an entire
city for us
like an entire city it was i got lost in
it i remember the first day that i
walked on set and i was in costume
already which was a coincidence it just
happened that that was the day that they
gave me the tour and i was at a costume
fitting and i went over there and i was
mind blown it was an entire outdoor city
that exists like ferris exists
it's not in a studio it's not parts of a
set that we filmed in studio it is
very much a city um
i keep saying like three to five city
blocks i could be wrong and i also could
be
maybe under
i'm not sure i'm not good with
distances one of the many reasons why i
loved it is that it was clearly filmed
on location
practical sets everything just looked
real you know it wasn't you know it it
just was very impressive um yeah i had
one i had one scene where they were like
um you gotta run and i was like all
right where do you want and the director
said what do you want
because they could point the camera
pretty much
everywhere i was going in one specific
direction because ferrix does have a
very specific geographical map but
either in this particular place that i
was both ways would leave me to the same
place so it was like
wherever you want um and that was really
that was really cool i'm like oh so you
can point the camera everywhere when you
signed on how much did tony tell you
about like the full arc of your
character what you'd be involved with or
was it sort of just like oh tony gilroy
star wars yeah i'm gonna do this no no
tony was
very much in communication before i even
i mean covet sort of happened so every
the whole industry sort of shut down and
and we were still talking
tony is is a true
gentleman
genuinely like creator where he is very
much involved i think with his actors
and
and is very open to conversations and
and
is constantly
telling me what is
what her journey was going to be like
and and oh i changed this a little bit
he really kept me
on the loop even before the scripts were
done and the second that he had a script
out you know we were all good at first
um
and even now with with the second part
i'm
he's already told me
you know
what's gonna happen and that doesn't
that's not usual he just really wants
you to get in that mindset and start
preparing your gears to sort of embark
in this new journey um and he wants you
to think on your own and think as big so
so i could sort of
then have my own ideas and and opinions
i would never give an opinion on his
writing because why would i would i
would make it worse
but it gives you the option and that is
what i'm
that's what is so
respectable of him i am in awe of that
man uh were you um like a big star wars
fan not a star wars fan before you were
cast and i have to know once you were
cast was it sort of like homework i need
to rewatch
all the star wars movies
it really was i i
um
i was a fan
i had watched the movies sort of
sporadically and sort of out of order
and i i was a fan but i wasn't educated
on sort of
the world itself um i'll be honest with
you and then when i got the job i was
like i need to do my
homework i was to be honest pretty
nervous about what i was about to join
and what i was about to embark um
so i i did i watched them all
chronologically
um i also needed to understand a place
and time and the place in
in history where i was because i think
vixx would know that and it was
important for me for her to feel smart
and to even though i don't necessarily
have to talk about it but i wanted her
to know that um
and so that was a must for me but i
think the cool part about this
show is that you don't have to be a star
wars fan and you don't have to watch you
don't you don't have to have watched any
of the movies to enjoy
this show
and and that's kind of the
the honest truth i think this show
really stands on on
on its own and i think i would the
reason why i say that the reason why i
love that is because you know it it'll
be great for star wars fans but it also
will be
a great show for people that aren't
necessarily so into star wars and
hopefully we can drag more people into
into this wonderful galaxy that we all
love i agree with you you don't have to
have watched star wars uh listen again i
loved it i can't wait to watch the rest
of the episodes um thank you for giving
me your time and you know uh good luck
with the rest of your speed dating
thank you
it was good to see you again nice to see
you seriously congrats show's awesome
thank you so much i appreciate it
you